what's up everyone thanks for checking
out this week in cloud where we serve
you the lowest latency news many teams
are looking at kubernetes an sto to help
manage their complex applications but
they still come up short when they're
trying to implement and host the actual
infrastructure at Google cloud next 2018
we first introduced the simple but
radical idea of a less disruptive and
more compliant services platform built
entirely on open api's we couldn't be
more proud to announce that Google cloud
services platform is open to everyone in
beta if you're currently using
kubernetes or running a hybrid of
on-prem and in the cloud you now have a
powerful tool to modernize existing apps
at your own pace google kubernetes
engine is the industry-leading managed
kubernetes service letting you focus on
your application and configuration
without worrying about the operational
security or infrastructure gke on-prem
brings that same manage kubernetes
experience to your on-prem clusters with
cloud services platform you can write
once and have consistent environments
plus a single source of truth for
configuration management there's a lot
to take advantage here so check out the
beta and see how CSP can help your
architecture speaking of modernizing
your applications if you've got some
Java applications lying around and you
want to look at containerization you'll
really like the cut of our jib that is
Google's open source jib project that
helps build Java applications into
containers you can easily integrate with
maven Gradle or by using the library
directly
Jib was just pushed to version 1.0 and
is now production ready so get building
even still migrating applications can be
a ton of work last year Google announced
that we're teaming up with Vale Estrada
to help people make that migration
process a lot easier
and now we're looking to team up with
Illuma experts in data migration and
integration so if you need some support
and migrating to the cloud or just want
to build the data pipeline Google and
Illumina have your back so we've been
talking a lot about Google cloud next
and all the cool things that are gonna
be showing off there but here's one more
cool thing you can get a free ticket to
next Google has released some new
certifications and quick labs content to
go along with those not only can you get
one month free of quick labs and get
your hands on training but you'll then
receive a discount for the certification
exam then if you get certified by March
31st you'll get a free pass to next
there's no reason to delay so get
started now and unlock
your cloud potential if you want to read
more about these announcements or see a
full list check out the link have any
thoughts or ideas leave us a comment or
tweet us we'll see you in the cloud